hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to let's
talk about the show Louie yeah I know
what the title card says I want to start
off by talking about loser
for those who don't know Luiz an FX show
centered around the fictionalized
Adventures of comedian louis c.k it's
gotten praise from both audiences and
critics and well the jokes and
characters are funny that's not what I
intend to focus on I intend to focus on
the stories or rather lack thereof oh
there's stuff that happens one episode
for example can consist of Louie going
off to see his daughters visiting his
psychiatrist going on a date and a lot
of times that's it there's funny jokes
and sex that occur but it's rarely bound
to a three-act structure and half the
time there's not even really a focus in
the episode it's just random funny stuff
that happens in Louis CK's life some are
even declaring it the real show about
nothing but how can that be when
Seinfeld is the definitive show about
nothing because that's what it is right
the show about nothing everyone says it
is even the series itself seems to
endlessly praise itself for it it's
about nothing
everybody's doing something will do
nothing I think you may have something
here I remember when I was younger
everybody was telling me to see it for
that exact reason that it was a show
about nothing a show that was finally
telling stories different not being
bound to a three-act structure and
focusing on a small series of problems
like all those other shows do that
sounds revolutionary actually just a
slice of unpredictable life where
anything can happen wow I can't wait to
see how TV is pushing the envelope but
when I would watch an episode I didn't
see a show about nothing because every
episode had a dilemma that needed to be
solved a toothbrush in the toilet
losing a car waiting to get into a
Chinese restaurant these were all
problems that had to be resolved before
the episode was over this was something
it was just small things then even then
they weren't all small things getting
into a fight with Raquel Welch that
seems pretty big getting the Merv
Griffin set tricking an animal expert to
beyond only to have your best
be attacked by one of his animals that
seems pretty big a menage tois this is a
little thing it doesn't look like it to
George then the problem was always
either wrapped up or had the other
problems when the various door lines
somehow all come together resulting in a
beginning a middle and an end with Louie
a story could begin or end anywhere
that's how much it didn't tie into
anything sometimes the story would have
the longer focus than usual but it was
still unpredictable on where it was
gonna go next how long it was going to
be there and when it was going to end if
it was even going to end as opposed to
just stop and don't get me wrong I don't
have a problem with three-act structures
or good storytelling but when a show
proclaims itself about nothing yet it
constantly acts like it is about
something I have to ask myself decide
the lie to us it all sounds that way
even when they claim themselves as mad
geniuses for their idea does the idea
really sound like the show we're
watching what kind of stories oh no no
stories no story so what is it what did
you do today I got up and came to work
there's a show that's a show okay
when have you ever seen an episode like
that the closest I can think is maybe
the pilot which really was just a day in
Jerry's life there was no focus at all
but as you all know the majority of the
stories always had a beginning middle
and end at least one dilemma and
eventually a resolution helped at the
time I was saying that The Cosby Show
was more a show about nothing oh sure it
had storylines half the time but the
other half could be just him at a
birthday party and that's it
a small family get-together and that's
it there was no problem to be solved or
conflict to be half again half the time
but that's more often than Seinfeld did
where there was always a conflict a
problem that had to be addressed now
before you Pelt me with cereal boxes
that have no copyright labels on them
let me make something perfectly clear
I love Psych though I still see it as
some of the best writing on TV ever the
characters are timeless the situation's
hilarious and the way the stories did so
often tied together I think
a masterwork of comedy I'm just asking
the question is it really about nothing
because I don't see any evidence that
states that it is so if it's not about
nothing what can I do Claire it's about
I mean okay we know it's about a
stand-up and his friends but what's the
more fitting description on the focus of
the stories well maybe it's a show about
how little things can turn to big things
a show about how middle-class America
obsesses over little problems as opposed
to big problems or a show about how a
comedian gets his material wait a minute
right there that's the perfect sum up
yeah because he always does to stand up
in the show right and everything they
talk about is something that a stand-up
would talk about that actually fits
perfectly well what genius said that
we're gonna do a show about how a
comedian gets his material well is it
heals the beaten path because clearly
he's stay in the show that it's about
nothing
I even remember they were saying that
George was representing co-creator Larry
David in the famous this show is about
nothing speech and then it pretty much
went as they showed it on TV so clearly
Larry David thought that's what the show
was about at the start right it was
going to be about how a comedian gets
his material or maybe they discovered
that show about nothing sounded more
marketable and funnier I guess I can't
blame them if people said your stuff was
genius for reasons you didn't think of
would you put up much of an argument
it's probably not you just go with the
flow bottom line when you really get
down to it it doesn't matter time Feld
is still a phenomenal comedy one of the
greatest shows ever written
and it's not like other shows that
really are about nothing don't get
praise either Louie is still a big hit
and both shows coincidentally start
stand-ups playing themselves which is
funny what do you think about it maybe
the next show will be so much about
nothing that would just be Jim Gaffigan
walking around with a webcam whatever
you call it and however you see it the
important thing is just to laugh at it
and both series show no sign of them
losing momentum there whether you think
their shows about nothing or shows about
something they're making you laugh and I
think that's all either of them
to accomplish colonists I was your
critic guy remembered so you don't have
to
you
boy it's Dominic video game confessions
it to tell you about the best of that
guy with the glasses volume 4 DVD we
what it's not strong enough player let's
try this vest on that guy with the
glasses volume 14 they day we unexploded
zest and a little things shaking but
that's not all we have so many of your
favorite videos that have been shown on
that card the glasses calm but on top of
that new material such as a brand new
nostalgia critic review of paranoia he
brought home of your paranoia no fuck
off horse thanks to new bum reviews one
of the ladies are ugly he's captured by
bad singing gladiator and one of Gingka
I'm gonna offend people by saying the
n-word a million times we also have a
continuation from the last us that guy
of the Colossus video all this time also
take a look at two new video game
confession starring yours truly one with
sub-zero what is your full-time job
they said being an ice cream man and one
would make a madman as a fan who's just
a little bit too obsessed brentalfloss
we also have the lost demo reel episode
transformers do you have any special
skills I have the ability to destroy an
entire Spielberg franchise with my mere
presence Wow we also have bloopers
deleted scenes commentary and more boy
the best of that guy on the glasses
volume for DVT I mean how can you say no
to it
really what if I throw in another
explosion and the penguin smoking of
shoot come on
that's a penguin smoking the shoe
you